bertrask northern sweden a small village
where you can get lit by magical lights
at night and during the day you can
worry about their great mystery
yeah somewhere between that house and
these cute reindeer and this giant row
of trees there is a century old enigma
involving
cheese
yep this big
ball of cheese
well as for all mystery towels a star
storyteller is essential and today that
is thomas rudin
yeah
westerbotnest is the emperor of swedish
jesus i've been making the westerbot
sauce nearly 40 years now
it was invented long time ago back in
1872.
the maturation is at least 14 months
because a good cheese will take its time
it's a very unique taste
it has a bitter and milky flavor and
older the swedes love it they put it on
basically everything
but for some reason it can't be made
anywhere else in the world aside from
this one factory
it's one of sweden's greatest mysteries
we have tried to make it in falchion bay
down in south of sweden also try to make
it in boldness and also in
but it hasn't been the real vegetable
and cheese
we don't get the unique taste and flavor
of it
and why
no one really knows some blame it on a
meteor that struck the village some 20
000 years ago which created this lake
and in turn enriched the soil with
calcium which affects the cows in the
region which affects the milk and cheese
they produce
another theory suggests the cheese's
unique flavor is influenced by the
bacteria in the air of the old factory
building
i mean the air is so precious to the
cheese's flavour that when the building
expanded holes were made so the air from
the old building would flow into the new
one
there's a combination with
the kind of milk that we are using from
the cows in our region combined with the
microflora in our dairy if we call that
magic or not
okay
one thing is certain this magic cheese
is kept alive by the people working on
it i feel very humble for the fact that
i i'm allowed to work with this cheese
it's a bit of the the mystery that's why
it's special last thing can you give us
the recipe
[Laughter]
no because that's the big secret with
this cheese
mystery solved
maybe
good night
good night
[Music]
you